ce sont des attaques qui ne font aucun
bruit mais elles sont virulentes
déstabilisante et elle coûte des
milliards de dollars aujourd'hui les
membres de l'otan y compris le canada
n'ont plus aucun doute
enquête à l'appui il accuse la russie
d'être l'auteur d'une série de cyber
agression à l'échelle mondiale on glisse
d'attac identifiés par londres il y a le
fameux piratage du parti démocrate en
pleine campagne électorale
les russes seraient aussi derrière l'
attaque contre la base de données de
l'agencé mondiale antidopage le centre
canadien d'éthique pour le sport et son
équivalent aux états unis que confirme
aussi la justice américaine ces sept
hommes ont tous été inculpés aux états
unis ils sont des agents du service de
renseignement militaire le glou quatre
d'entre eux seraient les mêmes que l'on
voit sur cette photo prise à la haye aux
pays-bas le printemps dernier il aurait
tenté d'infiltrer la base de données de
la grande organisation mondiale contre
les armes chimiques
celle qui enquête sur les attaques au
gaz en syrie et sur la sphère script a
c'est de l'acharnement de la manne
niveau a répliqué la porte-parole des
affaires étrangères maria à la cova
prostate qui se moque
une fois de plus que ce qu'elle qualifie
de cocktails diabolique
sauf que la russie aujourd'hui de plus
en plus isolé on verra ford coppola de
condamnation ou fait le tour du monde
toute la journée
si le canada n'écarte pas la possibilité
d'imposer de nouvelles sanctions à la
russie de possibilités pour autres
actifs
était maintenant c'est le processus de
dénonciation le ton se corse
mais le résultat reste le même et si la
russie est bel et bien derrière ces
attaques
si sur le front de la cyberguerre que
les grandes puissances de l'ouest que
vont concentrer leurs efforts et le
faire avec l'aide de l'otan
mais si thammarat ltte laisse couronne
au canada